it is now my great pleasure to introduce
my longtime colleague at Y Combinator
Paul Buchheit Paul is known for a lot of
things not the least of which is his
wisdom and all things when it comes to
startups but he's also of course the
creator of Gmail the inventor this is
true of don't be evil and has a has had
an incredible career so I just thought
I'd turn it over to Paul for a couple of
minutes for him to describe his journey
from somewhere to in into YC in the and
and what's happened then and we're gonna
have an interesting conversation I hope
on on what it means to build an epic
company Paul Wow all right thank you
how far back do you want me to go
exactly where were you born upstate New
York me too yeah so I yeah I grew up in
the Midwest and I went to college in
Ohio and like in the 90s it was just
different from now probably everything
in the nineties yes everything from now
it was different so yeah I was always
interested in startups and like you know
even as a kid like this idea I think I
just didn't like the idea of working for
someone else and also I liked the idea
that you could make a lot of money and
like create cool new inventions
basically right like you need to read
about inventors like Tesla or someone
like that like wow if only that guy
we're like smarter at business right
like he he invented so much he invented
so much and he made like he died
penniless like he wasn't smart didn't he
start that car company yeah I don't know
if he actually I'm not sure if he
actually got any equity I don't think he
did that so so yeah yeah I was always
covering the back of my mind but you
know as I'm coming up to graduate
college which was in 1998
so I was very interested in startups but
there really was you know there's
obviously no startup school there was no
Y Combinator there was none of was
basically very little the web was
relatively tiny at the time there was
not a lot of resources I didn't really
have any connections I didn't know
anyone who worked at a start-up but I
suspected they were like in California
so just always doing kind of like the
simplest thing first I've been treated
by that what made you think of
California I mean like eBay Netscape
like that first generation Yahoo all of
that first generation of Internet
companies say they had already you know
it's companies are IPO by the time I
graduated so and they were all located
here you know with the exception of
Amazon up in Seattle so you know it was
pretty obvious I didn't have to be that
Silicon Valley to figure out where
Silicon Valley is so so I took a job out
here at Intel kind of with the hope that
I would just like you know there but he
startups everywhere I'll just like find
one or something right so you went to
work for the man say yeah I went to work
at Intel and that was you know it tells
a big company it wasn't it wasn't
awesome it wasn't terrible it wasn't
like a bad job you know I don't want to
like but it wasn't it wasn't something I
look forward to like continuing to do
year after year you used to call working
at HP where I first worked the fur line
rut yeah
it's comfortable it's comfortable but
it's a rut yeah I actually have a
specific memory like hanging out with a
couple of other friends who worked at
Intel and you know I'm like 21 22 years
old something like that and they're
talking about like oh yeah they've got
this really great like retirement plan
where you know if you work there until
for however many years like your age
plus your number of years of service
like you could retire at like 55 or
something I'm like ah like it's like
like oh yeah why don't I just take the
next 30 years of my life and stick it in
a box and bury it yeah I mean it's worse
worse there are people there when you're
sitting there at 22 who have been there
for 30 years who are just kind of doing
time yeah so I wasn't really into doin
time but I was really into Linux so that
was kind of my obsession I'd gotten
interested in Linux like actually really
early like 93 like when it wasn't
actually very good and so I was kind of
like an early kind of Linux elet who was
like oh this is so awesome this is how
you know the future is gonna be and you
know back then businesses didn't really
Linux wasn't like a serious operating
system they're like no serious
businesses will always use Windows you
know you need like an enterprise
operating system not some hobbyist
junkie so I was like looking for
something to work in Linux and because I
you know everything at Intel was like
pretty much windows-based and so that
was my criteria when looking for startup
so it's just that I wanted it to be kind
of technically interesting Linux stuff
again there weren't like you know great
resources on like a huge list of startup
so I I just kind of like scouted out
what I could find basically on Slashdot
because I would I would read slash down
a lot and I came up with a list of like
six startups that seemed like they might
be interesting you know doing stuff with
Linux and so I like just emailed my
resume to all of them sort of like
ironically it immediately bounced from
Google because their mail server was
misconfigured so I didn't hear back from
from most of them ever I interviewed at
one other company and then they I resent
my resume the next day and then it went
to they had fixed like I think the MX
record was broken or something so I only
interviewed at like Google and one other
company and the other company like I
wasn't interested and I think maybe they
weren't interested isn't either one of
us really like contacted each other and
so Google was really the only offer I
had so that made it easy to like choose
and so I went to work there in 1999 and
how many employees did Google have I was
the 23rd at that point and so we were in
we were in Palo Alto on University Ave
kind of on the second floor above what
is I think a book shop or cafe or
something like that what did it feel
like at Google when they were
20 employees there it was really cool
actually like I you know I was really
impressed when I was interviewing with
them that they asked actually like
really smart questions which i think is
a pretty good indication like that was
one of the other reasons I wasn't
excited like the other startup I went to
that I'd interviewed at it was just like
I went into their office and I just sort
of felt the pressed like like you could
just tell people weren't really that
excited to be there and then they'd
asked kind of like dumb questions I
didn't think we're like anyway it just
wasn't like a good sign versus like
Google kind of like they were into
whatever it was they were doing and
actually after I was there for maybe
like a week I went back and I'm like hey
I want more equity like sorry you have
to negotiate that before you start so
yeah that might have been like the the
smartest pseudo investment decision
you've ever made even though it didn't I
guess it worked out but yeah I mean it
worked out overall but yeah I do wish
I'd gotten more more so the thing about
the office I mean you asked about the
environment like it just had like a very
kind of like a buzz of productivity
right like because we were doing these
really kind of exciting things and I
think like they had hired people who are
really into building these like big
systems and creating great products and
everything so it was it was an exciting
place to work where you know I would
actually like wake up in the morning and
be kind of like eager to go to work cuz
like I've got stuff I want to do do you
think that was because not just they
were working on exciting things but
because they believed they were going
somewhere yeah I mean there is there's
kind of like an irrational like belief
right like objectively we were just this
tiny little company river but you know
Larry would be talking about whatever
crazy ideas we were just like wow what
like I remember having an early memory
where I was building this system and
then I'm talking to Larry about he's
like why are you even bothering with it
disk we're just going to store
everything in memory or whatever which
at the time was sort of an absurd you
know we didn't have enough RAM to store
all the data but he was always thinking
like so many years ahead in
and it was a little bit insane but it
made it a very like exciting place to be
yeah it seems like there's there's
something fundamental if you're thinking
about whether you have a potential to
build a really big business if you don't
have some sort of vision some sort of
idea of a future it's hard to believe
you're ever gonna get there yeah I think
I think you have to have some notion of
the big picture and it doesn't mean you
look like a detailed step-by-step plan
like occasionally I'll run into a
startup where they're like here's our
five-step plan for how we become
whatever and like it isn't until like
the fifth step that actually they have a
product anyone would want to use if
those are like really bad I mean you
have to you have to have something today
that's good and you have to have
something tomorrow and you have to you
know day after day have like a product
that people actually want you almost
want a certain amount of vagueness
around your vision because if you have
too much detail you just guaranteed to
have wasted your time because it's not
gonna be right so you uh you spend how
much time at Google so I was like Google
for seven years so wow that's just about
how long you've been at YC now I've
actually been at YC from over seven
years now
mm-hmm so what happened during those
seven years stuff happened right so
stuff happened a few things so I yeah
what did you know like when did you
realize that Google was a thing that it
was going to be a like you know it's
this secular juggernaut that was going
to take over the world
earlier this year I I mean it bills I
got I didn't I I think I like many
people I continually underestimated its
potential but you know for very early on
kind of like after being there for a
week I was like ooh there's something
magical going on I didn't think it would
be what it is today as big as it is but
it definitely felt like we were somehow
creating the future and then when we
started really like like when we got the
Yahoo deal and started like really
welcome saying yeah we started really
just like pushing all just crushing all
the other search engines and then
there was like a feeling of
inevitability that goes pretty clear we
were just gonna win because no one else
like they just didn't even know what
they were doing like the competition
this wasn't very good before we move on
to your - leaving Google and starting
your own company it's just maybe say a
word about the founding of Gmail and and
how that happened
sure so email is actually a thing that
I've been interested in for a long time
I actually first into your resume
bounced yeah no actually before that I
mean in college I I had actually been
thinking a lot about this because like
again back in the 90s like people their
email would download to their computer
they would run like Eudora or something
and it would use pop3 to pull the email
down to their computer and I remember
people be like I need to go to my room
to like check my email and like that's
dumb like that doesn't make any sense
it's information it shouldn't be like
stuck in a box right
and so I I've been thinking about you
know this idea that like everything is
just gonna be online and then we'll just
like be able to access it anywhere
anytime we want and so I actually in the
summer of 1996 I think I kind of had
gotten maybe a little bit excessively
arrogant and had only applied for like a
couple of summer jobs just assuming they
would want to hire me and they didn't so
I sort of ended up without a job and
something like that's fine I'm just
going to start my own company and so I
actually tried to start this thing of
like a web-based email but I that's
funny because that's right when we were
building web-based email yeah mine would
have been better if I have 96 rocket
mail was really good anyway I had like
grand visions for it but I my approach
to developing it was was wrong it was it
was very much like I had this great big
grand vision and then I started trying
to implement it you know piece by piece
the components and then I got bored and
gave up yeah it's actually a
multi-person job to build email it's
it's a yeah it's kind of a lot of work
it's a lot of stuff but the
I went about it I was kind of wrong
because it was it was like I actually
like did sort of this detailed design of
this very intricate system and
everything and I've kind of come at
least for myself I've come to decide
that that doesn't work I need and this
is what we preach to the startups is
like figure out what you can launch
today and so to jump forward to to
Google like it was kind of 2001 there is
sort of a big reorg where they got rid
of all the managers and just gave
engineers more of a free range
engineering thing gave us all projects
and so they're just like I should build
an email thing like they knew I kind of
had an interest in email Robert but it
was it was just like we want to do
something in email we don't really know
what exactly like just go build it so
having learned from my prior experience
I decided to you know I think I kind of
know I have a short attention span so
the very first version of Gmail I wrote
in a day and it wasn't very good
but I took I previously been working on
Google Groups which was like a Usenet
search at the time now it's something
different but I took the code that I've
been working on for that and then I just
like took all of my email and shoved it
into that you know database into that
indexing engine and then you know I kind
of had an email search and they're like
yeah so your first thing was just an
email you could search yeah and so then
I like email that out to you know the
engineering team I'm like hey I built
this email search you let me know what
you think and then people reply like
yeah it's okay but it would be better
with my email instead of yours so like
all right I have a feature request
so first version zero only searched my
email isn't like you know the next
version I I made it so it would search
other people's email and but it there's
a stunning lesson in there I think which
is like the point wasn't so much that
whose email was being searched it was
that email was being searched like you
guys got to realize back then you
couldn't really search email all you
could do is like find the email you
wanted and click on it but so searching
was like a thing yeah and I figured I
mean a lot of our emails and
and so it sort of works right we're out
in a lot of the same mailing lists or
everyone see seeds so so yeah so then
version two is just like it indexes
other people's email and so I send that
out and they'll be like all right this
is cool now I want to be able to reply
to one of the messages
alright feature request right and so the
whole thing was just iterating the you
know to step by step trying to make
something that would make people happy
and so we actually had as our kind of
like launch gate this idea that we
needed to have a hundred happy users
inside of Google because we you know we
just had we hadn't launched it to the
world obviously and so I actually
embedded in the in the in the interface
this thing of a pop up and be like are
you happy yes or no it was just like a
single question are you happy with you
know Gmail or what was at the time known
as Caribou yes or no and and it would
get a list then I would look at of who
said yes and who said no and then I go
to all the knows and be like what's it
gonna take to make you a happy user
right and actually just get them one at
a time and some of the people they're
like it basically has to be a clone of
Outlook I'm like well you're never gonna
be a happy user now actually I did end
up getting more tips to me I know I I
did end up getting those people and the
way I would get them is that outlook at
the time when you would hit 2 gigabytes
in your in your mail file it would
corrupt the database and they would lose
all of their mail and then I had the
only copy of their email and so then
they would become a gmail user not
always a happy user but they would
become a user anyway other people it
would just be like a minor thing we're
like I just need to add one feature or
like fix a bug or something and then
they'll be happy and so we kind of
slogged through like just one user at a
time until we got to like 100 happy
users is that the genesis of you know
what we call it YC the poo height rule
maybe you can just tell these guys what
like it's better to have 10 right so
that one of the ideas is like when
you're starting out building something
new especially if you're kind of going
into an established category like email
like like literally you know email was
like 30 years old when we started on it
right so there is a lot of history and a
lot of opinions about how email should
be like people would sometimes angrily
tell me I'm like doing it wrong like
because we made the reply on top instead
of the bottom or like weird stuff like
that and so there's like all this
history so it's pretty much impossible
to enter a space like that and make a
thing that appeals to everyone and if
you try to do that what you end up
making is just like a mediocre product
that nobody really loves and so my
philosophy and what we try to get you
know all the stars to do is figure out a
thing that will just have really deep
appeal even if it's to like a tiny
fraction of people if you can make that
small fraction people just like
obsessively love what you're doing it's
easier to then grow that group you know
cuz like there's always people at the
margin where if I just make something
slightly better they're gonna join into
that group so it's easier to start with
that like that deep but narrow appeal
and then broaden it over time then it is
to start with just sort of like broad
men and then try to like convert people
from math to like loving your your thing
in mass yeah I've been thinking about
that lately just in terms of retention
like if you get a hundred people who
never leave that's a great place to
start then if you have thousands of
people all of whom turn eventually yeah
okay so Gmail happened and then you left
yes so [ __ ] happened and yeah a
couple years later I I left the the
company kind of you know it was becoming
a big company again and and I just
decided that wasn't the direction I
personally wanted to go and I just had a
baby who had a pretty traumatic start on
life so I kind of had other things going
on so actually around that same time
actually even before I left Google I was
again reading slash dot because that was
where I got all of my information and I
saw this thing about the summer founders
program which I thought like sounded
super cool because I'm always just like
looking for an idea that's actually
novel for those of you don't know the
summer founders program that's why see
that was the so that was a terrible
write that ended up being YC batch
summer o-5 that's the one that had read
and my chicken visit didn't say Sam's
company Justin and Emmett's company Kiko
we're all in that batch so I saw that
sir Khan is the founder of justin.tv and
and twitch and atrium so yeah a few
things a few things yeah so I was just
like really interested I didn't know
Paul Graham or any of these guys so I
was just kind of like keeping it on my
radar like I'm really excited to see and
part of that was it was my own
experience kind of like being there in
Ohio and thinking like I'm excited about
startups and I wouldn't even know where
to begin right because I don't like if
you go to Stanford like your roommate
probably has a startup or something like
it's just in the water but if you're
from someplace else if you're not from
Silicon Valley if you're not from this
environment it like it feels like you're
just excluded and and I really liked the
idea that it was just this open thing
like anyone in the world you didn't have
to know anyone you could just like
submit an application and they were
together like you know bring you in and
so like that idea
sorry to let startup schools the same
way now yeah exactly I mean what is it
that's the idea that I think like really
resonated with me is that it's like
opening it up to everyone even if you're
not kind of like an insider or something
so I followed them you know pretty
closely I want I was one of the very
first reddit users I think when when
that launched and then did you go to the
demo day no I didn't make it to the very
first that's the only one you ever miss
the only one I missed I I've been to
every demo day except the first how
actually is the distinction of having
been to more demo days than anyone yeah
than anyone including PG and Jessica if
it's a good distinction but as a
distinction yet it's a distinction so so
yeah then that fall they announced like
PG put out this thing hey for the second
batch we're gonna do it in Mountain View
like in this room it turns out and so I
was like oh that's cool I just dropped
them I didn't know my stomache old email
introduced myself and like hey if I can
like help out in any way just let me
know
so he's like yeah come on by and you
know I started just attending the
dinners and actually made my very first
angel investment in a company in the
second batch winter o 6 which was Kevin
hey
who then later became a YC partner wufu
which is a formed filler you know it
isn't like a company that I pee out but
it actually turned out to be really good
an investment nice first yeah yeah I had
I forget what the multiple is but pretty
pretty high yeah you know I thought my
first investment returned like 10x and
it was actually a little unfortunate
because it made me think I was better at
it than I was I think it's maybe like
50x so yeah hmm so yeah I so that was
kind of how I got hooked into this stuff
so I started at that point just getting
to know the founders in each batch and
I've invested in every batch since then
it's at least a few of the companies and
how did FriendFeed emerge during that
time so yeah after I left Google I sort
of like retired and then we just like
get depressed cuz it turns out tired of
it's not fun
yeah and maybe I have issues with
depression that I don't know so I but
working distracts me so I started
talking some other friends from from
Google who were thinking of leaving and
basically ended up starting a new
company which which was FriendFeed and
that was actually the actual goal of
FriendFeed which was just to build a
place that was really awesome to work at
I was actually just trying to create a
job for myself we tried to recreate what
it felt like when you're at Google in
the early days yeah kind of like the
best of parts because there was also a
lot of stuff about Google that I found
just tremendously frustrating and so I
kind of had this idea that like we could
take like the good parts and not the bad
parts it's like a little bit naive but
that was the hope and you know managed
to get like an incredibly strong team
mostly of a former Google people did you
ever feel like I mean frankly it went
fine but it didn't obviously end up
becoming like a hundred billion dollar
company did you ever feel like you could
pinpoint what was missing from from the
beginnings of FriendFeed that might have
led you on that path or what I mean was
there was was there
grand vision was that missing was it
it's a explosive growth was missing you
know social social is for those of you
don't know it was it was a social
network we actually created the like
button so like the very first like
button was on FriendFeed and then
mysteriously appeared on Facebook number
of months later they advanced instantly
completely by coincidence ya know
anyway social stuff is just really hard
even and we've seen this Ivan you know
we've had a lot of social stuff come
through YC you know Google has tried it
like it's a really hard space like
somehow some of these things that kind
of like you know Twitter or Facebook
they just kind of like catch and you can
go back in time and make up a bunch of
stories about like why it is and some of
those stories may or may not be true but
it's it's one of these things I think is
like one of the hardest product
categories to like engineer success so
but actually I will answer your question
which is that I I did sort of come to
realize this because in in the process
of you know trying to make friend foetus
success we kept running into this
company Facebook who who actually knew
what they were doing and and part of why
ultimately like I came to believe that
Facebook was just this unstoppable force
in that like we weren't gonna beat them
and Google wasn't going to beat them and
Twitter wasn't gonna beat them like no
it's certainly not myspace right like
none of these got any worse album it's
like having sort of competed with him
you start to realize oh they're really
good at this right and and I kind of
once I was inside so that was why you
know it sold front feed to Facebook cuz
I'm like wow this is gonna be like
another Google sighs there was that as
to what you were doing like Google was
their best in the world at what they
were doing when you were there and they
were the best in the world and you
weren't right and so it's just like I
should go there because it's gonna be
first of all I feel like another one of
these Google size companies and then
like hopefully I can learn how they do
it and I think like being there and kind
of reflecting not at one realization I
had
is that we kind of brought like Google
always had like a very product oriented
mindset like like we would try to build
products that were like like what the
user wanted so it's like you guys are
users you built product like you said
you built Gmail originally for people
yeah yeah
and so with front feet was kind of the
same thing of like we're just thinking
about like what do I want and I think
like one of the really powerful insights
that they had at Facebook was that it's
almost like the it's not the end user
who you have to please it's the network
because they understood that the most
important feature of a social network is
that your friends are there and so
sometimes there's actually a tension
between like what's good for the
individual and what's good for the
network and they would always do what's
good for the network do you think that's
just specific to network effect
businesses social media or is that a
more general rule do you think like an
enterprise product probably doesn't need
to think yeah I mean an enterprise kind
of has some of the similar thing where
you have to make the buyer happy not the
end user which is I think a lot of times
why enterprise software is not really
lovely to use is because the person
using it isn't the person with making
the binder so both cases you sort of
have to have a meta level where you're
like we always talked about making
something people want but people you
have to think more broader than just the
end user it's it's everyone who's
involved in the in the system right
right and it's people get this wrong a
lot of times where they think like
there's this meme out there that like oh
if you're not paying you're not you're
the product not the customer wherever
but it really isn't right like you have
to identify whose happiness makes you
successful so like for Google it really
is like the end like the people using
Google search like if they go to a
different search engine like there's
Google screwed right like you have to
keep those people happy and you know
with the Enterprise example its whoever
the buyer is in the I think the sort of
subtle thing with with Facebook was was
that what makes those people happy is
that you have this like huge network
and so work that's that's efficient and
easy to use and right and so and so you
really have to think in terms of like
almost what the network wants which is a
different way of thinking yeah so when
you when you were you friend Pete was
bought by Facebook and so you you landed
in facebook did it have a similar feel
to their I guess Facebook was a little
bigger by the time you got bought but
did it have a have a Google like feel
then I mean there are a lot of people
from Google hey hi you know former
co-workers similarities and differences
so that was again one of the things one
of the reasons I was excited to go there
it was just like I had had this
experience going through Google and it's
very easy to over generalize you know
like oh wow the reason we were
successful is we had like you know
brightly colored balls or something like
that like you can make up all of these
like the rationalizations for what made
you a success but in retrospect
everything looks the truth is I think
like the majority of the reasons you
come up with are probably wrong there's
there's like a few key things I will say
though that like going into the office
it kind of had that vibe of like this is
a place that's going somewhere right and
and I think it's like a really powerful
indicator and it's a subtle thing and
it's a little bit almost metaphysical or
everybody like you walk into an office
and you're just like how is the energy
how does it make me feel does it when
I'm here is that like when I watch my
own energy levels am I going up is this
making me feel like oh wow or is this
like pulling me down am I like depressed
because and I think the reason that
works is because the employees actually
know what's going on right and so if
you're just there cuz like you're
collecting your paycheck while you wait
for the company to go bust like you're
gonna have a different energy from yeah
you feel that if it versus if you think
like oh my god I need to launch this
thing it's gonna be so exciting like
it's gonna take over the world right and
I guess it's just a very exciting
feeling to have like these products like
like when we were building Gmail and
maps and stuff like there was this
feeling this palpable feeling of like
this is gonna blow people's mind so
buddy put it out there right like
that's a really exciting thing do you
think so part of the energy comes from
these amazing products that you're
building but it seems like part of that
has to come from the founders and the
just the attitude that they bring the
belief that they bring like whether it's
soccer or Larry and Sergey yeah
absolutely I mean I think that there has
to be a founder conviction like they
have to believe in what they're doing
and not that they're just chasing after
you know some trend like oh I read an
article and TechCrunch I'm gonna go off
in a new direction I mean I actually
think like Zuck is probably the most
extreme example of this I've seen I
almost feel like the whole world could
tell him he's wrong and be like no and
and and this is really reflected and
some of the I think internal mythology
of the company there's a really
interesting and this is before my time
but you know back when they were just a
college social network they had
something like 10 million users which
first social network isn't that much and
Yahoo wanted to buy them for like a
billion dollars and everyone is like
used to take the money he actually took
the money but then a change that they
like they're gonna changed theirs and he
didn't want it there was pressure on him
right so like everyone around it was
like pressuring him to take the deal and
then by the way if you get offered a
billion dollars take the deal right
in case you have any doubts right and so
finally yeah I mean ultimately turns it
down basically replaces an entire
management team after that because they
were all kind of like we should sell we
should sell I mean so he kind of brought
in people who who maybe believed a
little bit more oh and then there's kind
of actually the story I meant to tell
wasn't even that it was that when they
launched the newsfeed the which was
around the same time and people right
hey they were furious and and so again
they were like something like 10 million
users unless something like 8 million of
them joined a group protesting it like
like it's impossible to get that
percentage of your users to do anything
even if you want them to so to like
suddenly have the majority of your users
like a revoltin or whatever and they're
just like no I think people
we're gonna come around on this in there
you know right obviously look at the
newsfeed is like a fundamental thing but
that receipt is Facebook for most people
right right there's nothing else but I
mean that requires I think like a pretty
high level of conviction when
essentially all of your users are
furious at you and you're like no I
think you're going to come around on
this the for somewhat unclear reasons
this reminds me of another bukit ism
which is that that sam actually repeated
in his introduction to the course which
was that you know what a company really
needs is frugality focus obsession and
love and it seems like like if you
encapsulate those things even in the
very beginning and you think about
leaders like zack that they kind of they
kind of go together and make sense yeah
yeah i i think like focus is one of the
most important things because like as a
start-up it's actually i think your most
powerful weapon right like the reason
that you're able to take on like these
big companies or whoever is because
they're doing a thousand different
things right and so the only way you can
win is if you take everything you have
and you focus it at one point right
because you you are underpowered in
every way versus these other companies
so the one thing you do have that they
don't have is you can be like absolutely
100% focused on the thing that you're
doing and that was like you know with
google that was part of the reason that
we won it search was i was all we were
focus on like early on right is and you
became the best in the world at it like
you versus like everyone else's ago we
want to be a portal right we need all
this other [ __ ] so like that that's
really key frugality i think is also
really essential I think like one of the
best indicators of if you're doing it
right is essentially your input to
output ratio so you want to do more with
less
unfortunately most startups do less with
more so like you give them money and
they just burn it up and there's like no
results so like being able to to produce
a lot of outputs with a minimum amount
looks like amplify time and money right
but you have to like amplify the mean
get that ratio where it's
I give you a dollar and you turn into
ten dollars my god that's a good
business right like we just scale that
thing up even if it's ten dollars worth
of something like ten dollars worth of
product $10 worth of innovation and so
and this goes back to always figuring
out how to do things in the absolutely
minimal way and minoo it means this is
one of the key startup things where
they're like it you know if you if
you're not embarrassed of your product
you've waited too long to launch like
these things are at the root there
there's a lot of like frugality there
right because you don't want to spend
too much time or too much money like you
want to get it out there as quickly as
possible in as little cost and well so
you don't want to spend too much time
running on the wrong thing and you just
don't know enough right right a builds
way too much email and you wouldn't have
learned what to actually build right
it's easy to go completely off the rails
and it's one of the most surprising
things like I've learned just working
with so many startups is how often the
cause of death is too much money
like I think there are companies that if
they had not been so well funded could
have been successful in the company I
like to make fun of not because they may
have been successful but just because
it's funny to laugh at is juice arrow
like the the $700 juice bag squeezing
machine and the thing that made that I
think such a like tremendous trainwreck
is that they gave them a hundred and
twenty million dollars for that thing
before they ever like talked to any
customer like if if juice arrow had gone
through YC and we gave them one hundred
and twenty thousand dollars they would
have had to go talk to a customer and be
like hey like we want to sell you the
seven hundred dollar juice bags right
they would have had to talk to customers
like like and that's the thing like we
push so you have to go talk to your
customers is so easy to become detached
and off in this like bubble of delusion
in the problem with having lots of
funding before you're really ready for
it is that's exactly what happens so you
can you can sell yourself on this idea
oh yeah once we build the perfect juice
bag squeezer like we're gonna take over
the world everyone's gonna want to spend
$700 I mean plus is like you get this
giant box in the mail
has tiny bags of juice in it is awesome
like everyone's gonna want this right
and they were able to live in that
delusion for years because they never
had to go out and talk to customers but
if I refer a call you could actually
just recreate everything you did by just
going like that right the reason for it
so I cut open one of the bags
the reason is I think to actually get it
to work they had to really heavily
macerate the fruit so that's why I call
it a juice bag squeezer because it was
actually already juiced it was so is
really just separating the pulp from the
juice which is why also it's no better
than just like going to the store and
buying juice like the whole thing was
like built on a number of flawed
premises but but like in particular you
weren't really even juicing it has
already been juiced you're just
straining the juice but there's a deep
lesson there which is no matter what you
raise if you raise fifty thousand
dollars or five million you you should
think of the amplification you need if
you raise five million dollars that
doesn't mean you can create 150 thousand
dollars worth of value and be happy you
have to create 50 million dollars worth
of value yeah but you can't like it's
easy again I think to come up with
stories in your mind about how you're
doing it because like once we release
this you know juice squeezer it and and
that's why I think like you just have to
stay close to the customers you have to
be out there selling because you can
just become delusional otherwise and so
that's why you know with startups like I
I've just seen it again and again like
if they get a huge round of funding
before they have product market fit it
kills the company like it because
because it's just too hard for the
founders to resist that because actually
going out and dealing with the fact that
you don't have product market fit it's
really painful it's easier to tell
yourself stories about how oh yeah we're
killing it I'm hiring I just hired a
whole new team we've got this cool
office like there's all these like a
cool technology yeah we're doing all
this amazing stuff right I'm in the
press all the time I go to conferences
I'm up on stage you know like there
knows like it's easy to just kind of
like be completely detached from reality
because because you're not out there
selling a thing
McCrea ting a thing that people actually
want to use we were talking earlier it
seems like there's this is this
interesting juxtaposition that that if
you really want to be creating an epic
company you have to be thinking about
the future but you better be paying
attention to the past at the same time
because there's a lot of lessons to be
learned about what goes wrong more
things go wrong than go right with
startups and yeah III mean that's just
the past but I think more importantly
the present like that's the thing like
you have to have some some you have to
maintain kind of like a dual like a
dream or a vision of like what that
future is of you know something that
gives you an orientation like I need to
head in that direction like like I think
about you know the Lewis and Clark
expedition or ever they're like we're
going west we're going that direction
but like you don't really know all the
streams and rivers and forests and
mountains you're gonna have to cross
along the way right you but so you have
to be very focused in the moment so that
you don't get like eaten by a bear or
something like that but at the same time
you have to have that vision of like
where you're headed and so I think those
are kind of the two things I being a
visionary alright yes like between you
know just paying incredible attention to
your current customers right and having
take over the world right and I think
the thing that happens with too much
money is you just spend all of your time
like dreaming of like the Promised Land
but you're not actually dealing with the
problem that's in front of you we may
have I want to turn over to Q&A and we
may have covered most of this already
which is fine but you've been spending a
lot of time with YC batch companies
doing I think what you're called a
hundred billion dollar office hours
which is which is my understanding is a
way for you to help them think about
what it might mean to actually become an
epic company what are the like you know
there two or three things maybe that we
haven't talked about that you cover in
those office hours I thought this would
be like a group office hour a hundred
billion dollar office I yeah all of our
startup school companies yeah so I
thought a lot about you know what is it
that makes these these companies that
are you know Google Netflix Amazon like
all of these like just huge huge
companies like what is the
that gets you there in it's not this I I
don't think it's that you're smarter
necessarily it helps to be smart it
isn't that you're harder working there's
a limit to how hard you can work what I
think necessarily to get to that point
you're sitting on top of a big
exponential change in reality or in the
world so like you know Intel and
Microsoft in in the early days Apple
we're kind of sitting on top of this
like the rise of micro computers right
and so like what made Microsoft a big
company is that they got in early on
micro computers and then they kind of
owned that space right where the micro
computer operating system you know and
they were they were able to ride that if
we weren't from microcomputers like they
wouldn't have been able to do that and
likewise you know Google obviously was
sitting on the growth of the Internet
that the reason that Google made sense
in the in the thing that part of the
reason other people got it wrong was
they weren't thinking about the fact
that the amount of information online
was increasing exponentially and so we
were gonna have to get a lot better at
like or organizing it right like googles
mission from the beginning is to like
organize and make useful all the world's
information and people are always
surprised that they're aggressively
gathering information it's like right
there in the missions David all the
world's information game sososo I what I
try to have the the founders I kind of
give them a two-part question and so the
first part is like let's say I hop in my
time machine which is hopefully a
DeLorean and I like travel ten years
into the future so I get out it's the
Year 2028 you know I take a look around
I like grab some nearby people and talk
to them or whatever I ask questions like
what about the world of 2028 is
fundamentally different from 2018 like
what's what's the thing that's totally
different right
and so the Trump will no longer be
President
yeah yeah we don't really know the
future you just completely derailed me
that was the first thing out of two
anyway so the thing is what I want them
to do is identify the change and this
should be as it pertains to their
startup because obviously there's gonna
be a bunch of changes but as it pertains
to your startup but factoring out your
startup because even if like Facebook
didn't exist I guarantee someone would
have built a giant social network right
like Facebook was was was sitting on top
of that exponential change and they were
the ones who were most able to like
capture it that position and hold on to
it but if it wasn't them I guarantee
someone else would be in that ecological
and estimated ability there's a Nevitt
ability these companies will exist in
some form and maybe you're making it a
little bit faster or a little bit better
or something like that but that position
is gonna exist and then the second part
of the question is simply like how are
you gonna be the one who captures it
right so let's do some Q&A
any questions what's the tipping point
where you really approach the market and
you know know that you're going to
convert a lot of it for us and customer
interviews about 80% of the people want
to try what our product does and we even
have people pay 40 bucks for a cup of
coffee I just take my money so what's
your question so how do you identify the
tipping point and really how you execute
that tipping point that gets a market to
that so the question is how do you
identify a tipping point for a market I
almost feel like this is being over
thought if you've got people who will
pay you $40 for a cup of coffee I would
just start selling $40 cups of coffee
like that sounds like a really good
business
and very profit the tipping point is
when you can't keep up with demand
right and so again like you don't you
don't find this by thinking about it if
you think about it too much you end up
just like in delusional land you find
out by talking to the market and having
them give you dollars and and and so
it's it's like literally when you're
just like scrambling to keep up with
with demand and that and that's the
thing that you get into in these like
hyper growth companies like one of the
biggest problems inside of Google is
like we couldn't build datacenters fast
enough right like things are just
exploding so quickly that you can't even
scale out that's that's what tells you
that that you have that yeah I kind of
hit you over the head right it's not
like you don't you don't have to give
instruction for when you're in hyper
growth you know you're there in the back
practices for enterprise companies where
maybe you can't launch something that's
really really bad because there's
requirements around security etc so the
danger I feel like with a lot of these
enterprise things is that you end up not
really solving an urgent problem because
like when you talk to people they're
like oh yeah this is it would be great
to have this solution or whatever and so
then you go off and you build this thing
you spend years maybe building this
product and then you go to them you're
like here it is we got it and like you
know we're really busy this quarter and
actually we don't have it in the budget
until maybe next year so can we talk
again in nine months or something right
like and that's just deadly for a
start-up like so the way I try to think
about it is you want to find someone who
has a really really urgent problem right
and so like the analogy I like to use is
like imagine that your arm is pinned
underneath a boulder
and you have two options one option is
to like knopf your own arm like with
your teeth or the other option is to
sign an LOI with this promising young
startup like right right like that's the
kind of customer you want is like
someone who's like desperate right and
because they're desperate they're
willing to put up with kind of a shitty
product maybe they're willing to spend a
lot of time working with you right and
so like actually one of the things that
works really well like is is is if the
founders are actually able to just go
into the organization and actually work
there so like that was how like the very
early stripe installs Patrick Collison
would show up and integrate stripe into
your code you just show up and do the
work and so like that's a good thing and
if they're not really eager to have you
come in and integrate into their systems
or talk to their people or whatever like
maybe they're not in enough pain and
like you need to go find a different
customer who's in more pain and if it's
a big enough market there's got to be
someone who's desperate back there you
believe in using personas to represent
your customers do I have that right not
really
don't believe in using people to
represent my customers sorry common
denominators for the founders hundred
billion dollar companies so this was
actually where the focused frugality
obsession and love thing came from is I
was actually trying to distill it down
into a small enough number of words and
then I was here to try to translate it
into emoji but I failed at that part I
couldn't figure out the I couldn't
figure out what is the emoji for
obsession like love I like okay a heart
but there is I think like this obsessive
focus there's there's almost an
irrationality in some of these founders
like the
example that comes up as like the most
insane version of it is probably like
Elon Musk
so I actually he came into Google gave
like a Tech Talk
I want to say 2003 or something like
that and it was it was after he had
started SpaceX but before they had done
the first rocket launch and someone is
like what are you gonna do if the rocket
explodes when you launch it he's like
well I have enough money for three
launches so I hope one of them succeeds
like he literally ploughed his entire
fortune the first three blew up - I
think yeah the first three did Lobby
that he managed to scrape together
enough money for like a fourth rocket
yeah but that fourth rocket hadn't gone
there would be no SpaceX and Elon would
be bankrupt right like he like that is
insane I would not take all of my money
and plow it into like some harebrained
rocket scheme right like that's like a
level of irrationality that is I think
like wonderful so I think the question
is how come Google never made it in
social networking you know it just
wasn't I think really in the DNA so we
actually like had even before Facebook
do you remember Orkut like we like it
was we actually could have or you know
at the time like in Brazil right yeah
well it became big in Brazil but I
actually tell you like orchid actually
was taking off and you can make up a
bunch of reasons why maybe it didn't end
up being the social network but it was
exploding and then it became it was
growing so fast it became unresponsive
so like it just that was kind of why it
died off in at least the United States
is that it was
so slow but part of the thing is that
within the company I think like it just
didn't resonate with people enough like
it wasn't really it didn't become this
crisis we're like oh my god we have to
make this thing succeed it was kind of
like this thing that's over here to the
side right and so like Google is very
much about like these really interesting
big computer science problems and stuff
like that like that's what really would
get people excited and this stuff kind
of seemed like a distraction I mean like
the founders of Twitter or at least like
two of the three founders of Twitter
where Google employees right like like
and they never would have built that at
Google because like if you had built
it'd be like what is this thing there's
nothing technically interesting about
Twitter right and so I think it just
wasn't really in the DNA and then when
they did try to do it it wasn't because
like it wasn't because like you know
Larry has a deep love for social
networking or whatever right it was
because they wanted to be competitive
with Facebook but by then Facebook was
way ahead of them and had a much deeper
understanding of like what makes this
stuff go so if you're behind and not as
good you're guaranteed to lose it's not
a good outcome so I think we're going to
call it there thank you very much Paul
you
you